[Music]
on this tuesday night v-day
in the uk the world's first clinically
approved kovid 19 vaccinations
begin how happy it's happened what
canada can learn from the uk rollout
and why people in long-term care likely
won't get the initial doses
the logistics of this rna pair plus how
the first doses in canada will be doled
out
dire new predictions for alberta and the
new restrictions
finally on the way rising food prices on
the menu for 2021
what's driving up costs and the pilot
who blazed a trail the first human to
crack the sound barrier
the tremendous achievements of aviation
hero
chuck yeager
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
after weeks of warnings from doctors
about the virus spreading in alberta
virtually unchecked
premier jason kenney now says hundreds
if not thousands of albertans
could die unless new public health
measures are imposed
as of today all indoor and outdoor
social gatherings are banned in alberta
masks are mandatory in all public indoor
spaces including workplaces
but it won't be until december 13th four
days from now that other restrictions
kick in including a ban on
indoor dining and the closure of casinos
bingo halls fitness centers
and hair salons premier kenny said he'd
only impose these kinds of restrictions
as a last resort
alberta seems to have reached that point
the question is
whether it's too late across edmonton
hospitals have been expanding their
covet wards by the day
the patients arriving in a seemingly
endless stream we know that we're
already behind the eight ball
in terms of the next two weeks but i
think it's after that
if if we can if we do absolutely nothing
right now
um we are going to be in crisis
come january the high case numbers a day
after alberta's top doctor made it clear
that without new measures infection
rates would only
rise alberta's premier says new
restrictions are now required
to prevent hospitals from being
overwhelmed we know that if we allow
viral spread at current growth rates we
will eventually run
out of hospital capacity that is not an
opinion it is a fact
the new measures include a mandatory
mass mandate casinos restaurants pubs
and hair salons will also be closed
we are now at a place where viral
transmission is so widespread in the
community
that it does not any longer matter how
careful
uh business operators are these
are decisions that we have
arrived at not as a first resort but as
a last resort to protect lives
and to preserve our health care system
small business owners in edmonton were
among those calling for the new
restrictions
in an open letter tuesday the edmonton
independent hospitality community wrote
we cannot access extended federal
support because a formal lockdown has
not been instituted
prioritizing the economy over covid
suppression is a false dichotomy
the new measures follow an ultimatum
delivered monday by alberta's big city
mayors
if the province wasn't going to act the
cities would
still this isn't a full lockdown retail
stores have to further limit capacity
but shopping malls can stay
open meaning a scene like this at
calgary's chinook center on black friday
could be possible come boxing day places
of worship
will remain open as well the new
measures come into effect at midnight
sunday and will remain for at least four
weeks
the lives of hundreds of albertans now
depending on whether they succeed
heather urex west global news calgary
in manitoba code red public health
restrictions have now been extended into
early january that means no gatherings
outside your household
over the holidays that's going to be
difficult
it's going to be lonely for many but the
best thing we can do now for our loved
ones is to stay apart
so that we may be together in person
next year
today manitoba reported 245 new cases
and 13
more deaths the premier says there are
signs the restrictions are starting to
work but he says
now is not the time to let up now to a
milestone moment the first dose of
optimism in what has been a dismal year
a 90 year old woman in the uk has become
the first person in the world to receive
a clinically approved coronavirus
vaccine
just before 7 am retired jewelry shop
assistant margaret keenan
made history getting the first dose of
the pfizer biontech vaccine
she turns 91 next week and said this is
the best early birthday present
she could wish for
it is welcome news not just in the uk
but around the world
so much hope of a return to normal life
resting
in these tiny vials it's been
just 332 days since the first death from
covet 19 was reported in china
and it's since invaded every country
infecting more than 67 million people
and killing more than 1.5 million people
these initial doses of the pfizer
biontech vaccine are the start of the
world's biggest
mass vaccination program canada is on
track to be next in line to get it
because it needs to be kept at minus 80
degrees it is a logistical challenge
in the uk the first doses did not go to
residents in care homes it was given
to people aged 80 and over who are
already in the hospital
along with nursing home workers and some
health care staff
crystal commansing on what's been dubbed
the day in the uk
i'm happy it's happened and now i've
done it
and hopefully it'll help other people
come along and do as i did
do as i did might be the 2020 version of
the old
rosie riveter we can do it campaign
covet 19
has been talked about in battle terms
and margaret keenan
is the face of britain's vaccination
counter-attack
so make this um floppy and this arm
floppy
all right yeah watch it boot
that's why i'm in navy sir people over
the age of
80 and some medical workers are the
priority
50 hospitals are being used as
vaccination sites because the pfizer
biontech shots
must be kept at minus 70 degrees celsius
the mass vaccination effort is a
historic step forward
for the uk i'm feeling very emotional
today it is really quite remarkable
and we less than a year ago were
treating the first patient we covered
the virus has caused immense anguish
families kept from dying loved ones
non-urgent surgeries canceled
and medical staff pushed to the edge
i mean in terms of how the nursing
profession is feeling in the uk
they are tired they're exhausted they've
had an extremely stressful
year 2020. but it's not over yet
millions need to be inoculated so far
the government has enough
vaccine for 400 000 people but
some fear a shock produced in just 10
months
it's safe it's the right thing to do
it's good for you
and it's good for the whole of the
country they want to know how it applies
to them what are the risks and how would
they be able to obtain it
and so we've got a big public health
communication task ahead of us in the uk
and indeed i'm sure in other countries
the hope is eventually the vaccine will
shield society
from its current enemy crystal
commansing global news
london those planning the vaccine
rollout here in canada are closely
watching the uk to see what lessons can
be learned
although the hope in the uk was to
vaccinate residents in long-term care
homes first
that is not happening with this pfizer
vaccine and today canada's chief public
health officer said it may not happen
here either
the initial doses are likely going to be
given to people who can
physically get to one of the 14
vaccination sites
the concept at the beginning of rolling
out the fisa vaccine
is to try and sort of keep it at the
point
of use that's for a start
but it's true that you cannot move
residents very easily from a long-term
care facility
to a vaccination site so that's just the
realities
health canada is expected to approve the
first vaccines later this week
working out the delivery plan is like
piecing together a jigsaw puzzle
involving the federal government
the provinces and the vaccine
manufacturers mike derolay looks at how
canada's vaccine rollout
is coming together in a research center
not far from ontario's legislature
in a nondescript hallway adjacent to a
row of lockers
sit the most important freezers in the
country just need the vaccine as soon as
it
arrives we're ready to go non at the bit
right now
how ready is debatable since the initial
delivery of doses from pfizer need to be
stored at -70 celsius or colder
once the vaccine begins to thaw it's
only good for a few hours
meaning canadians will have to go to
where the freezers are
and the most vulnerable canadians are
also the least mobile
it's a rapidly evolving situation so
i think everyone has to remain flexible
and adaptable
complicating matters is the continuing
surge of covet 19 cases
as well as more outbreaks and facilities
like the 242 bed westside
long-term care home in toronto which has
had 117 residents
and 57 staff members contract the virus
in the last month
nobody is going in or out and dr don
bodish says it's likely the outbreak
will need to pass
before residents can be safely immunized
the best option
right now she says is to immunize the
staff the logistics of this are a
nightmare the logistics are an absolute
angle
how do we get this vaccine to our
country
frozen the fact that we don't have
manufacturing on site
is a problem and then once it gets here
how do we distribute it equitably
the first vaccine has yet to be doled
out and already the concerns are as big
as the plan itself
plans which epidemiologists hope aren't
written in stone
you know a good plan is better than a
perfect plan and so getting more arms
and needles together with
not really having much of a planning
time where the vaccine is sitting in
fridges
is a whole lot more important now
microlight global news toronto
administering the vaccines once they are
delivered is up to the provinces and
territories and they're developing plans
and priorities
based on their populations david aiken
explains what we know about that
38 million canadians but there's only
enough of the first batch of vaccines
from pfizer
for about 125 000 people to get their
first dose by year end
so how to divvy that up ottawa and the
provinces have agreed to share those
first doses on a
per capita basis so that means about
forty eight thousand in ontario
will get their first shot by year end
twenty eight thousand in quebec
seventeen thousand in bc fourteen and a
half thousand or so in alberta
and less than five thousand in every
other province
because of logistics issues associated
with pfizer's vaccine
none will get their dose for now in the
three northern territories
but the provinces have sole jurisdiction
when it comes to deciding
who will be first in line and each
province is making slightly different
decisions
most put residents of long-term care
facilities at the top of the priority
list
while ontario and alberta insist staff
as well as residents in long-term care
homes get top billing
quebec puts long-term care staff and all
health care workers in that province
that's about 325
000 people as its second priority group
ontario's number two group is anyone who
works or studies in a hospital
and that would include everyone from
food preparation people to
maintenance crews to doctors and nurses
alberta's number two priority group is
anyone over 65 living on a first nations
reserve
once those groups are done each province
moves to its third priority in alberta
that's anyone anyone over 75 years of
age
ontario will move next to focus on
adults in indigenous communities while
quebec will vaccinate seniors living in
retirement homes or private group
residences
still federal officials continue to
insist that
every canadian who wants a vaccine will
get it
though it may take until the end of next
year to complete that objective
david aiken global news ottawa
nova scotia has explained its plan to
roll out the vaccine the first
shipment of nearly 2 000 doses is
expected to arrive by december 15th
frontline healthcare workers are first
in line long-term care residents and
staff and people over 80 will be
immunized
during the first three months of 2021.
it will most likely be the summer before
the vaccine is offered to the broader
community in nova scotia
the u.s president-elect joe biden is
promising to deliver an ambitious
inoculation program
as soon as he takes office 100 million
shots in the first hundred days
and will follow the guidance of science
to get the vaccines of those
most at risk
the weeks before that though will not be
easy the u.s continues to lead the world
in covid cases and deaths and among the
victims
are those who worked hard to save lives
dr carlos arohou-presa
was a specialist in respiratory diseases
in houston texas
an immigrant from el salvador he cared
for the sickest coronavirus patients
in april he slept almost every night at
the hospital always
on call in november he got sick himself
he ended up in the intensive care unit
where he served as the critical care
director
he was eventually put on a respirator he
died november 30th
my dad will never see me graduate from
my master's program
he'll never give me away at my wedding
he'll never see his grandkids
coming up growing grocery bill what's in
store for 2021
air canada is cutting more services in
atlantic canada
in the new year the airline will suspend
all flights to sydney nova scotia
effectively
cutting off cape breton island from all
commercial air travel
it's also cutting roots into deer lake
charlottetown fredericton and halifax
in june air canada announced the
indefinite suspensions of 11 routes in
atlantic canada
westjet also suspended 80 percent of its
atlantic capacity
in october it's been a difficult year
for many canadians who are trying to
make ends meet and the cost of putting
food on the table
could be another hurdle next year the
latest edition of canada's food price
report anticipates the cost of groceries
will go up in 2021
some items by as much as six and a half
percent
mike armstrong explains why
something rare happened in the butcher
business in 2020
the price of chicken beef and pork all
went
up and butcher shop owner patrick dubo
says that doesn't usually happen
at the same time it is rare usually you
have one that's able to save the other
well there's a prediction it's going to
happen again in 2021.
if anyone was hoping their wallet might
get a break that
doesn't appear likely unfortunately our
models are
suggesting otherwise professor sylvester
labour
is the project leader behind the
canadian food price report
its prediction for 2021 would see a jump
in the cost of most
basic items in a shopping cart baked
items will go up 3.5 to 5.5 percent
vegetables 4.5 to 6.5 and the same for
meats
one of the biggest culprits is covid19
for example
meat producers have struggled at times
packaging plants have had to be closed
due to outbreaks
but it's not just that part of the
supply chain that's a problem
it's all of them it's costing more to do
everything in livestock
and in processing the other big issue is
weather and
climate change 2020 was a difficult year
for growing in much of the u.s
that's meant for example produce grown
here in canada that would usually stay
here
is being sold to other markets and
prices are going up
put all those different increases
together and what does it mean for the
wallet well an
average canadian family of four is
spending about twelve thousand five
hundred eight dollars on food in twenty
twenty
next year that's predicted to be close
to fourteen thousand
an increase of six hundred ninety five
dollars about
five percent i mean that's that is a lot
of a lot of money man
when food prices increase it affects the
most vulnerable most of all
and drives up the need for food banks
but it also makes it harder for those
food banks
to buy what they need mike armstrong
global news
montreal
ahead will and kate join the queen to
pay tribute to frontline workers in the
uk
reaching the summit of mount everest is
quite a feat
and it turns out the climb is a little
bit higher than everyone
thought nepal and china the country's
mount everest straddles have agreed the
world's largest peak is
8848.86 meters high
and that is 0.86 meters higher than the
original survey
done back in 1954. for years the two
countries have disagreed on the height
of everest
china's measurement only included up to
the rock peak
nepal's calculation apparently included
the snow packed
on top of the rock
well for the first time since march
britain's members of the royal family
have reunited for a special tribute
the queen prince charles and camilla
plus prince william and kate met outside
windsor castle to thank frontline staff
and volunteers who have been working
through the pandemic
the event marked the end of prince
william and kate's royal train tour a
three-day trip to thank workers
across the nation
the remarkable life of chuck yeager next
a salute to the first
supersonic pilot
we end tonight with the story of a
humble man who pushed humankind beyond
all limits chuck yeager died last night
at the age of 97.
he was a test pilot the first to fly
faster than the speed of sound and he
blazed a trail for others including
canadian astronaut chris hadfield
hadfield paid tribute to jaeger today
calling him a brave and singular man
who served his country expanded
scientific understanding
and inspired me eric sorenson on a man
whose achievements
sent america's dreams into the space age
his daring spins training to be a pilot
in the second world war
showed he was a natural in the cockpit
and when he shot down
five german planes he qualified as an
ace in a single day
but chuck yeager's mark on history would
come two years after the war
as a test pilot in the x1 a rocket plane
built to break the sound barrier we
didn't even know that we would ever
break
mach 1. it didn't make any difference to
me whether i thought the airplane would
go fast and sound
i was signed as a as a test pilot on it
and it was my duty to fly jaeger
from the belly of a b-29 the x-1 was
dropped into the sky in october 1947
the rest was up to jaeger scientists
didn't know whether the plane would
break apart
or whether jaeger would survive smashing
through the speed of sound and he does
it
the first human to crack the sound
barrier
the cockpit shook furiously that moment
recreated in the hollywood film the
right stuff i'm still going upstairs
yeager's death-defying achievements
blazed a path for the first astronauts
who would follow his contrails
he was supremely self-confident
he was genial but he had a razor-sharp
mind on anything involving high-speed
flight
jaeger would continue to break aviation
records he was the first pilot to fly
twice the speed of sound
you don't look at it as being dangerous
it's something that you're sort of
dedicated to and that's your job and
that's what you're going to do and
and you don't really think about the
outcome
jager personified the aw shucks courage
that it took to be the first to test
life and death at supersonic speeds
he marked the 50th anniversary by
breaking the sound barrier again
i just tell people i'm no hero i just a
kid that
you know it's the right place the right
time chuck yeager didn't actually
believe in having the right stuff
he believed in hard work and learning
from experience the secret he said was
that somehow
he always managed to live to fly another
day
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is two jack lake in banff
national park thanks for watching hope
to see you here again tomorrow
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]